welcome to this video a new part of the
calculation and technique serious this
is from the game between two English
players Stuart conquest playing white
and Michael Hennigan playing black you
might know Hanigan from my channel I
have played him in number of times in
blitz chess Stuart conquest the strong
English grandmas and nowadays not that
active anymore on the tournament circuit
is very much involved in chess in
Gibraltar he's organizing the great key
browser open every year I think is also
involved in other chess projects them
and let's have a look at this game this
is from 2007 played in the four NCL the
British chess league white here played
the move rook a1 the whole situation
here is quite clearly from a Kings
Indian defense where this typical pawn
chain in the middle of the board this
kind of thing defines the whole position
white has a space advantage and he has
the more is more attacking targets on
the Queen side considering also that
those pieces are not not really great
strategically speaking
why does not better but it is still not
an easy process to to make headway from
here because black has some things going
for him an active Queen this Knight is
also well placed always putting pressure
here yeah rook a one was played in this
position the black player now played the
move Knight to a4 and this is the reason
why this is part of the calculation and
tactics serious and not a part of her
Sam Miller game strategy thing where we
want to look at how to play against the
Kings Indian structure after Knight f4
the situation becomes
highly technical and the task
I'm giving us to look at this position
and now find the best continuation for
white okay should pause the video now
I'm going to it going to show it to you
okay let's have a look at this I'm going
to show you the solution
quite quite shortly yeah night a for a
funny move it attacks the Queen of
course and while you cannot take here
it's a pin so hmm what what does this
mean it's 94 all of a sudden leading to
a good position for black what should Y
do let's have a look um 90 X a formed
it's the the most most obvious move but
then black will recapture and in fact he
can even recapture with the rook if he
takes with the pawn and if you
calculated that and then you probably
even came to the conclusion that command
a3 is still good for white yeah the
situation on the Queen side is opening
up and we have more pieces there to
attack especially this week d6 born
however black also has this possibility
and after rook takes a four things are
not that clear one problem is that in a
situation where we have everything
traded like let's say for example
something like that and we just let's
just continue that to to show you the
whole thing if we come to a situation
like that the whole proceedings are
shifting to the to one flank is just
happening on the Kings side and on on
the center and while white is still a
little bit better he has only one very
apparent weakness d6 which probably can
be defended so this is not leading to
that much but what else is there what
else is there after Knight a form the
green hangs to the knight hangs
what else should white play Congress
found a brilliant solution to the whole
thing he played the the absolutely
astonishing move rook a to and I find
this extraordinary rook a to what is
this proof doing is just ignoring the
attack on the Queen yeah the the big
point is that if after okay to black
takes the Queen White grabs the rook
with check black interposes it does not
matter Bishop f8 is the same thing and
then white has the amazing resource
Knight a to attacking in the Queen and
this Queen is trapped yeah this is
extraordinarily difficult to see at the
at the start of the whole thing the
Queen has no squares the somewhat we had
moved Knight a to at exit
it takes away c3 he cannot go here or
here on the ephod and all its protected
by whites pieces so black is losing the
whole Queen for just one piece I can
sacrifice it like that for example but
in this type of position why this just
very simply winning even this Knight is
totally stranded on b2 it has nowhere to
go so an amazing resource the point is
really that very often you have to check
if a threat a very apparent threat is
really a threat the move if we go back
the most Knight takes b2 it's not really
a threat as there is rook a a check and
Knight a to this is very difficult to
see but in fact white actually could
consider and move like h4 in this
position because there is not Knight B
to is not threatening the difference
between a move like h2 which is not
doing very much and rook a to is of
course that after rook a to you protect
your queen and this means the move B
takes a for is threatened also note that
of course black can never take c3
because well this is
so very simple capture on it with an
exchange up so Luke a2 is fled out
winning the thing it's just like that
why does threat need to take any form
and black has has no reply relief he
played in the game I would actually did
he play I think I'm Luke c8 is what he
tried
there is really no move to be honest he
he tried to hang on for a bit trying to
find the actual game continuation with
it
rook c8 yes here it is rook c8 and after
that white white can just take like that
yeah and here we come to the to a
situation that is a very easy win as we
attack d6 so often that black cannot
defend it it's just a just a hopeless
hopeless position something like that
we should f8 happened H form Group C 7
rupee form Bishop d7
Andrew P 6 and D 6 was indefensible yeah
you didn't need to calculate that form
the the big point here really and that
out at the start of it is that you need
to recognize that after night a4 there
is no attack on the Queen it's very
often the case that we automatically
assume an attack on our piece is really
in effect it's not really always the
case very often we can answer with a
counter threat or it is simply not a
real threat but sometimes it is very
difficult to see it is I think in this
case exceptionally difficult to see that
rook a to putting it on a - exactly
then taking here and then Knight a - is
trapping the Queen it's a fantastic
resource to find um yeah maybe you found
it I think I'm not sure if I would have
managed that it's it's very very tricky
to see and great that a conquest spotted
it in the game yeah I hope you enjoyed
this little piece of this little piece
of tactics and yeah calculation and
tactics videos are coming all the time
and look forward to the next one thanks
for watching